Jiu Jitsu is 100 of superpower there's
no doubt about it my son he asked me
when he was a little kid the movie The
Incredibles came out and he said hey Dad
is there really such a thing as
superpower and I said yes there is it's
a little thing that you do every day
it's called Jiu Jitsu and eventually he
realized that oh I can actually fight
anybody and it's gonna be fine because
there's always I guess I'm a little bit
biased because of the way how I grew up
there's always violence there's always
some sort of inferred level of violence
I mean a seal platoon there's a pecking
order and it has to do with fighting and
that's the same with any group of
knuckle dragger Neanderthal men there's
always a guy that's he's the one that
can kind of beat everyone up the way it
is I'm sorry that it's that way I'm
sorry it's not a cerebral contest